[Music]
influence in this country that says it
is okay for people to push allegiance on
country
congresswoman Omar caught on tape making
vile anti-semitic remarks suggesting
that Jewish Americans hold dual
allegiance to the US and Israel
Republicans pushing for a martyr be
removed from the house of Foreign
Affairs Committee over the controversy
Democrats don't have the vote
use sense room anyway joining us now is
former Speaker of the House Newt
Gingrich for reaction and by the way the
host of the new podcast newts world what
does it mean about a Democratic Party
that has a severe bigotry racist and
anti-semitic problem and can't get
enough votes to condemn it well I think
it tells you how strong the forces of
the left are now there's a deep
anti-semitic anti Israeli bias on the
left there are a lot of people on the
left
who'd be very happy of Israel
disappeared tomorrow and who feel a
hundred percent on the side of Hamas
even while it's firing rockets at
Israeli cities so I think what we've
seen is over the last thirty years a
growth in the anti-semitic behavior on
college campuses and a growing
willingness by some Democratic
politicians to be very openly
anti-semitic and anti-israel and I think
the second thing is that a lot of the
younger militant members whether they're
anti-israel or not they are deeply
opposed to Nancy Pelosi trying to
exercise any discipline he's not the
speaker no more clearly is about she's
not that I mean I mean she's clearly
losing look she is losing control of the
house that they may be forced in a
desperation move to change the house
rules to block Republicans from offering
anything which would I think lead to
chaos but she can't get her party to
stay together and if you're a modern
district of here in a district the Trump
carried or if you're in a district
that's heavily Jewish and you're
watching the Democrats go crazy and you
are a Democratic freshman running for
reelection this has to be a really
decisive moment right who do you stay
with let me ask you know so you come to
power with the Republicans for the first
time in 40 years you and Bill Clinton
decided you wanted to do great things
for the country and you ended up doing
it and I'm not a big fan of Bill Clinton
but you did balance the budget which we
haven't done since and a lot of welfare
reform so many big things he even said
the era of big government is over into
welfare as we know it you guys found a
way to govern even though you had
opposing views you see now the Russia
collusion narrative is collapsed so now
they just move on to the next thing
which is the widest net ever cast to
basically look into any and all things
Trump rather than govern how does that
end no I think it's been in very badly
but let me be clear this is this is not
an investigation this is an act of hate
these are people got they're basically
saying if you work for Donald Trump as a
private citizen we're gonna try to
destroy you
we're gonna make you hire lawyers we're
going we're going to make you go through
public humiliation I mean these are
normal everyday folks who are not in the
political arena they're gonna call it in
front of some of these committees and
the most radical vicious nasty liberal
Democrats are going to feel that they
have a right to beat them up to
humiliate them to lecture them and I
think this tells you I mean we're moving
I was thinking about you know Jim
Sorrentino wrote the hateful six he
could have written you know the hateful
eight for the Democratic Committee
chairman and made a movie out of it but
we have never seen at least not since
the Civil War
the kind of deliberate vicious character
assassination
not just at the trailer not at the
president president Trump's a big guy if
they want to fight with him he can
better gone after everyday folks you
know when Adamson hires when the author
of the steel dossier
Christopher steel doesn't support his
own dossier but Adam Schiff hires the
only conspiracy theorist and person that
does believe it that tells you a lot but
you know it when David Axelrod says this
is beginning to look like a witch-hunt
this is like and and Mayor Bloomberg
says this lurch to the left not gonna
end well
when people like that or saying things
like that I think if I was a Democrat I
might listen but I don't see any hope
that they ever would well you don't know
what's gonna happen yet because the
truth is as all these candidates line up
to run for president I don't think any
of them want to get in a fight where the
Left haisa
is taking them on so you see over a
hundred Democrat House members have
co-sponsored a bill that eliminates any
private sector insurance that's a 15%
position you're gonna see a Democratic
Party unacceptable to most Americans no
cows no planes no cars no combustion
engines everything's free and we're
gonna confiscate all your money great
idea and no children
remilia you can be got to think of twice
about ever having any kids and the
world's ending in 12 years